فقد دعا رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي السابق
يهود باراك الى العصيان المدني في اسرائيل
في حاله تمرير خطه التعديلات القضائيه
ودعم راك في مقابله مع شبكه الامريكيه دعا
رؤساء المؤسسات الامنيه الى الوقوف ضد هذه
الخطه
هو هجوم على روح ديمقراطيتنا وعلى استقلال
المحكمه العليا وقيم اعلان الاستقلال
بمجرد ان تستخدم الحكومه ادوات
الديمقراطيه لتدميرها من الداخل وتتصرف
بشكل غير شرعي فانه ليس من حق المواطنين
اللجوء الى العصيان المدني فحسب بل من
واجبهم ولكن يجب ان يكون عصيا غير عنيف قد
يكون امامنا اسبوعان او ثلاثه اسابيع قبل
الانتهاء من هذا التشريع وامل ان يقف ضده
رئيس جهاز المخابرات ورئيس الشرطه ورئيس
هيئه اركان الدفاع الاسرائيلي